هذا الاسبوع سيكون مهم جدا حيث
اننا هذا هو نموذجي ورمز وهذا يدعم يعزز
صمودنا وكذلك مقاومه
ونشكر السيد الرئيس الولايات المتحده على
زيارته هذه الازياء بالتاكيد
سيكون عليها اثر على ساحه المعركه وان
قرارات الولايات المتحده بالنسبه للدبابات
كل ذلك مهم للغايه وهذا اساسي
لنا وهذا شيء مهم على مختلف الجوانب وخاصه
فيما يتعلق بالدفاع وكذلك
النظم الباتريوت وهدس يعزز قدراتنا ولقد
تحدثنا عن الاسلحه وكذلك الاسلحه التي
اوكرانيا هذا العدوان يهددنا جميعا
فان كل البلدان للعالم والنيتو والحلفاء
كلنا وحتى اليابان
عبر العالم بقمته العلم الكل له هناك اكثر
من خمسين بلد الذين ساعدوا اوكرانيا على
ان تدافع على نفسها وذلك بتقديم الدعم
العسكري
والانساني
وبالتالي فهذا كلف
كثير
ونحن جميعنا
فلقد
وطن اكثر من 700 دبابه وكذلك الكثير من
المركبات
والانظمه وكذلك اكثر من مليون من
المعدات الاخرى وكذلك
الانظمه الدفاعيه البحريه وذلك للدفاع عن
اوكرانيا